コロンビア人に漢字を聞く
だってね今だと大体そういう大きいパリとかロンドンとかそういう大きい街だと必ず日本人学校っていうのがあるんですよ
日本人のお子さんたちを1週間に1回でも行かなきゃいけなくて私の孫たちもあれ行けば行かなかったよね
だけど大気とか行って行くようにしてたのよね
だけど私は最初フランスに行った時はもう日本語なんて全然もう聞こえもしなくてフランス語をやるのを知ってもうきちだったんですよね
本当にもうイエスも何も言えなかったから
本当に何にもわからなかったから大変でした
何歳でフランスに行ったの?
小学校終えたところでちょうど12ぐらい
12、3になる時だったかな
いきなりフランスの学校に入るわけですか?
フランス語喋れなくて日本から行って
そうそれでもうクラスに入れられちゃって最初はだから全然できないんですよね
そちらは本当におめでとうございますね
英語だけは日本で私は精神に行ってたんですね
だから英語は小学校だけは少しやってたから
英語の方がフランス語よりはできていて
それでフランスに行った時に英語のクラスとそれから数学、算数のクラスの簡単な計算だけはできたんですけど
それをフランス語で言うことはできなかった
なんか大変だった
それは大変ですよね
本当に大変です
僕ら全然フランス語わかんないでね
フランスで行って
3ヶ月ぐらいフランスでブラブラしてた
この人入院しちゃったんですよ
それでその時すごい困って
アルルで、アルルの総合病院で入院したんだけど
アルルで唯一ある総合病院
そこの一番大きい病院なんだけど
英語が喋れる看護師が一人
ドクターも誰も英語を喋れない
辞書
これこれの名前ね
今はね、あの、翻訳機があるけど
昔は辞書でこうやってやってさしながら
大変です
あなたは今日はここへ泊まるべきだ
ん?
入院?
入院したんだ
入院しちゃって
英語喋れる総合病院
その地区の一番大きい総合病院で
英語が喋れる看護師が一人だけ唯一
ちょっと心細かい